bueno empecemos por hablar de qué quiere
decir Joe biden y porque esto no se
trata de un rescate por parte de Estados
Unidos a los bancos y le complementó el
mensaje de Joe biden porque él también
dice se les va a respetar el dinero a
los ahorradores pero no a los
inversionistas Y es que una cosa es
tener el dinero dentro de ese banco y
otra muy diferente es ser inversionista
del banco y tener acciones en este
primer caso el presidente dice que sí se
va a responder por la totalidad de los
recursos que hubiera ahí y en el segundo
caso asegura que no se les responde a
los accionistas porque ellos De antemano
saben lo riesgoso que es invertir en
acciones es decir un banco de un día
para otro pueden no costar nada y los
inversionistas se quedan sin ese dinero
vayan a hacer énfasis en que no es un
rescate porque los recursos no van a
salir del presupuesto Es decir de los
impuestos de la gente sino que se paga
es con los mismos activos del banco que
fue intervenido y además esos depósitos
están asegurados a través de la
corporación Federal de seguros de
depósitos que responde algunos casos
hasta por montos de 250 mil dólares
aunque se ha dicho que se va a responder
inclusive si el monto es mayor Daniela y
por qué quebró el silicon pues para
hacerlo resumido todo sucedió por la
subida de tasas de interés estas
empresas tecnológicas que tenían su
dinero allí que eran sus principales
clientes ya no se estaban endeudando
sino retirando recursos por este alto
costo del endeudamiento como empezaron a
sacar masivamente el banco tuvo que
devolverles a tantos al mismo tiempo que
salió a buscar financiación en el
mercado con una emisión de acciones esa
emisión no solamente fracasó sino que
tumbó el precio de la acción de este
banco e hizo que hubiera una corrida
bancaria esto María Clara es cuando
Todos quieren retirar su dinero al mismo
tiempo y ahí es cuando el gobierno
decide intervenir que es tomar posesión
del banco echar a sus directivos y
quedarse con sus activos para poder
repartirlos entre las personas Bueno
usted nos habla de esta corrida bancaria
Cuál es el miedo y por qué se contagia y
podrían ser los impactos Pues el miedo
María aclara básicamente es que el
mercado es muy sensible a esta clase de
situaciones porque les trae a la memoria
lo que pasó en 2008 pero por más que se
garantice que no va a haber un efecto
dominó el nerviosismo sí está imperando
en Las bolsas por ejemplo el índice
bursátil latinoamericano se dirige a un
mínimo de casi un mes el peso mexicano
también hace lo propio el real de Brasil
el peso colombiano están a la baja el
día de hoy Wall Street Si vemos estaba
listo para extender todas esas pérdidas
del viernes pero las palabras de vaiden
también tranquilizaron a los
inversionistas Y eso hace que las bolsas
estén mixtas eso también trae un mensaje
de que la reserva Federal podría ser
menos agresiva en adelante para evitar
este tipo de situaciones vemos en Europa
por ejemplo como si cerró con pérdidas
cercanas al 3% a pesar de que las
autoridades dijeron que la exposición a
este banco es limitada por el momento